(rap music)
("Last Day" by Shallou)
- [Gary] They're build shops.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah, totally.
- [Gary] To me this is like out.
- [Man] Yep.
- [Gary] For me just 'cause
I feel like I've
really gone there mentally.
- [Man] Yep, yep.
- [Gary] Like I
think once, to me...
I have to put myself in
the best position to succeed.
If I don't think of
myself as an investor,
if I just read the
tea leaves of society
and deploy, I'll win.
At the end of the
day from my perspective,
the world I live in,
small little world,
this is a table that's
completely naive to where the
consumer's
attention actually lives.
I think about agencies that are
doing 1 to 5 million and what we
can do for them
versus what they can do for
themselves independent.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] It's a one
plus one equals eleven.
- [Man] Yeah.
Totally agree.
- [Gary] Okay.
I'll let DRock take the fall.
I do like that.
- [Other Tyler] Cool.
- How was Romania?
- [Gary] Quick.
- Yeah.
("Underwater" by DigitalLuc)
- [Gary] I really
wanted to edit.
- Stock boy.
- [Gary] You love that part.
I wanted to take that part out.
That's what
I wanted to edit out.
- How you doin'?
- [Gary] Really well, brother.
We're really used it.
How's everything?
- That is awesome.
- [Gary] That?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] This artist is so good.
So whatever we're
doing inefficiently is super
interesting to me
and, there's two buckets,
inefficient, which I know
how good you are at,
and offense.
Know whatever
they're gonna wanna do,
I'm gonna slightly move
it towards the upside of art.
- Yeah and they know
and I talked them through.
- [Gary] Upside is this, right?
- [Marcus] Exactly
we have to like,
regardless of anything, one we
have to do what's gonna work
and then B, we're
not doing this program,
we're setting
the foundation but,
you know, one after this.
- [Gary] Okay.
Everybody out.
- [Tyler] It's this.
- [Gary] This, then?
- [Tyler] 7:45 HiQ.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Tyler] Call.
- [Gary] Then Andy.
- Andy.
- [Gary] Then Phil.
- Then Phil.
- [Gary] That's it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Okay, yeah.
Good, sounds good.
How are you?
Good to see you.
- Jeff and Alan and Mark--
- [Gary] Yeah?
- all of them have been
like we kinda need to get
together as a crew.
- [Gary] Okay.
How are you my man?
- [Man 2] Good, man.
- [Gary] It's
really interesting,
you guys were talking I
just had a guy by the name of
Erik Kastner in my office.
Erik Kastner was my first
developer at Wine Library.
It was so emotional for
me even like seven years,
day in, day out like this.
I didn't travel back then and
then I haven't talked to him for
six or seven years and I reached
out to him the other day random
and said hey, I want you to come
and be my personal developer for
my chat bot,
for my Alexa skills,
for all the stuff I want to go
on the tech offense 'cause I got
everything on the content
down but I don't have that tech
partner right now.
Hip hop really taught me that.
Hip hop, I'm 41, and I was
really into hip hop and when
I was in high school,
hip hop was really hardcore,
you had to be a gangster.
Guys, as you guys know, made
up their backstories to make it
seem like they came from tougher
places 'cause you couldn't be
accepted the way you
can now if you grew up in,
you know, I was
thinking about 8 mile,
the last scene, right?
Clarence's parents, you know.
(group laughter)
But it's interesting.
When it changed,
after Pac and Biggie
got killed and people
were like fuck, let's
talk more about like...
And it was
happening a little bit before.
When it got into champagne and
it got into like polo shirts and
umbrellas, Bentley, right like,
when it got into
a different thing.
When it was like oh my God,
all those kids
thought that was cool.
And then when,
I'll never forget it,
when I saw Lil Wayne start
caring about skateboarding,
I was like okay something very
weird's about to happen because,
yeah.
And you've seen it, right?
It's just in a
totally different place.
And now entrepreneurs
hold that pedestal.
- Yep.
- [Gary] Which I think is great.
I think a lot of
you agree, right?
- Yep.
- [Gary] Now the key
is to teach kids patience,
long game, self-awareness,
doing it the right way.
You know, some kid
sent me an email yesterday,
and he said, "You've changed
my life because I grew up in a
"really shitty neighborhood and
everybody taught me that
"hard work was for suckers."
And it really hit me, I read
it like four times last night.
And he's like, "You know,
hard work was frowned upon.
"That you had to find
your way for the short move.
"The quick score, the angle.
"That you were
good if you did that."
And it's really like already
I'm trying to
manifest it in my content.
I'm like okay, I got to
figure out what that means.
So, anyway, that's the answer.
That's a very long
winded answer to you know what,
I can sit here and
talk philosophy all I want,
but I'd rather do.
That's why entrepreneurship
can save this thing because it's
real hard, real hard to become
Jerry Rice or
Lil Wayne like real hard.
There's only so many slots.
But you can make $97,000 a
year with your small little jam
business or SaaS business.
It's there.
It's that the long tail of ROI
of building your business is so
much longer and that's why I'm
excited that entrepreneurship is
winning culturally because a
lot more kids are gonna build
$100,000 a year life for
themselves than you know,
'cause it's feast or
famine in athletics and hip hop.
Right?
("Underwater" by DigitalLuc)